(dramatic music)
(gasps)
- Where am I?
Hey man, who are you?
What's going on?
- You were in a coma, be quiet,
I'm watching the latest
episode of Fargo.
- What, Fargo?
That's not a television show.
That's a movie like Lethal
Weapon or Training Day.
- Shh, those are both TV shows.
- What?
No, man, I'm talking about
movies in the theater.
You're talking about
TV shows on television
like Entourage or
Sex in the City.
- Shut the fuck up, man.
Those are both
movies, by the way.
- What?
No, movies are
full-length-cinematic releases
like Teen Wolf, or
Scream, or Catfish.
- Those are all currently
television shows on MTV!
Shut the fuck up!
- Quit fucking with me, man!
- I'm trying to watch Fargo!
- TV shows air episodically,
weekly, on television
like CHiPs, or Baywatch,
or 21 Jump Street!
- Movie, movie, movie!
- You're fucking
killing me, man!
Movies are different.
Movies are longer.
Movies are things like
Taken, Hannibal, Rush Hour,
Psycho, Limitless,
Shooter, Westworld!
- Shut the fuck up, asshole!
- God damn!
- Those are all TV shows!
- Fuck you!
(screams)
- Dammit, that's piss!
- I can't deal
with this anymore.
Shut the fuck up.
I just want to read
my god damn book.
Where's my copy of
Girl on the Train?
Where is it?
It's always next to me.
- Are you talking about this?
- Why is that so shiny?
- Because it's a fucking movie.
- That's not a fucking
movie, man, that's a book.
- It's a movie, and guess
what, they ruined it.
- How dare you?
It's a perfect book!
- They ruined the movie!
- Oh fuck!
(flatline beeps)
(sighs)
And now I missed
the end of Fargo!
(flatline beeps)
- Hey guys, do you know Three
Musketeers is a candy bar now?
Guys?
Fuck.